I I want to thank the Academy for making
this event happen and for making such a
beautiful print of the film yeah give
him an applause yeah and I mentioned I
I'm n shinned I'd love to bring Jackie
Taylor on the stage because she is a
perfect prime example of the power of
film to affect people's lives and I've
always you know kind of rankled at
people who say what you see on the
screen doesn't affect you the violence
the whatever you know it in it affects
you tremendously it has a anything that
goes in our brains sets a pattern
it sets a template for actions that we
either do or do not and the impact that
Cooley high had on you Jackie was a
launching pad this lady started a
theater company in Chicago one year
after the movie opened that theater
company is still running 44 years
in 2011 she raised twenty million
dollars to build a theater it's a
state-of-the-art theater a theater so
her work is continuing the work of
Cooley high you want to talk about that
just real quick well yes I was I was
totally what it did was it said it said
to me your dream dream big
don't-don't-don't put a cap on it dream
whatever and I wanted a theater with the
mission of the black ensemble theater is
to eradicate racism and through the
power of Cooley high and the message
that it gave I had the courage and the
strength to say I'm gonna make this
happen and yes we have lasted we we did
build a wonderful twenty million dollar
facility and now we are going to ensure
that black ensemble theater lives way
beyond Jackie Taylor because we have a
seventy-five million dollar neighborhood
development that we are building around
the theater that will feed into the
theater and let us do what we need to do
it beautiful